I began right feet eight years ago with the F117
Three days in I felt much sicker 10 days in the old injury sites began feel much worse than three months
in the die-off
I purged
So question is when you I think the question is because I know the person who asked this question was doing fantastic right now
But when you start right feet for
Infection, so what use when you use the right?
To kill an infection especially a gram negative bacteria like
Borrelia burglar or feet
It kills quite quickly the right works
And it's very evident when you have a line disease that you use
The right machine if you have the presence of a
bacteria
Then it is going to
Kill the bacteria and if it's a gram negative bacteria
It's going to elicit what's called lipopolysaccharides from the cell membrane and you're gonna end up with what's called a herximer reaction
So a herximer reaction is when
You produce a lot of endotoxins in your body that could overwhelm the immune system in itself
And it can make you feel
Really yucky can make you feel like flu-ish fatigue, you know, you just feel really lousy
If that's a case you need to slow down on whatever therapy you're using
To make sure that you you know, you can overcome that because you can make yourself sick so you have to slow down
Now I will say that
Some will will say that they are hurt their hook seed short for herximer reaction
Is very common term in the live community
But they're not really experiencing a herximer reaction
So if you have
If you're killing directly with the right machine, you're running birelia
Frequency with the right machine and you're herxied then that's a sign you had
Still the presence of the bacteria and
By killing it off
Directly using the right because the right is it's stimulated in immune response. It's killing directly when it's killing live
Is your your you will
You know
Produce a lot of endotoxins and the endotoxins produce would kill a gram negative
Bacteria are like a polysaccharides which I'm going to make you feel ill
um
So that's a sign if you run the right
And you have a chronic life and you're running live frequencies and you have a herximer reaction that is you had
Or have the presence of
Live bacteria still in your body. So then you just got to slow down and go at your pace that you can to tell you get it up
You've killed enough where now you could run a longer program if you don't feel ill
And now you could deal with the comorbidities of live disease
Um
But many people will take immune stimulants. They'll say well every time I take um, you know
Let's say um my a stragglest or my um
You know might have a C dose or my live disease. I herx and then I have to back off for a couple weeks
And I do it again for a couple weeks that I herx and I have to back off for a couple weeks
And these people were diagnosed maybe 10 years ago
Well, the truth is they may not have the presence of
um
Back to they're not really herxied. They're not killing bacteria producing endotoxins and feeling sick from that
It's that they may be in phase three they have
Antibodies to self tissue and every time they're stimulated in immune system
Response by taking a supplemented herbal or a vitamin C or a garlic or something like that
That is a direct immune stimulant every time you stimulate your immune system
If you have self antibodies, you're going to kill self tissue
So this quote-unquote herx reaction that this person experiences actually the symptoms of
Self tissue destruction. So you have to be careful of that again. How do you know that you have to do testing after on some labs